I didn't want to tell this but now that
John's I can't believe you're telling
this story I would have never said this
story I would have taken this one to my
grave well me too but you're here now so
I guess it's okay let's talk about you
so this is what happened remember a
couple of days ago Robin I said to you I
went with a friend in their car and you
were like you went in a car and my
friend you're trying to picture it and
my friend and I drove to Nowhere for
three hours
it was John John called me up and he
said listen you got to get out of this
Howard Zone you're in like I think he
was doing an intervention
but John called me up and John says we
need Taiko well where are we going to go
he goes I I love to do this I get in my
car
I put the radio on and we drive by the
way John what was that [__] car we
were in it's so tiny John I get in there
you love that car hold it holy [__] I
get in the car it's a I'm six foot five
yeah I get in the car it's this little
it's a two-seater
I get in and John goes hey
if the first thing I say to John is John
this is a horrible idea you know that
it's only going to go but you're gonna
be miserable with me because all I do is
complain he goes no we're doing this
we're gonna get in the car and we're
gonna drive you very positive guy yep
and then he says to me gee think this
car is going to be too small for you yes
I did yeah consider it and he says
because I'll drive home and get a
different car I said oh no this will be
fine my knees are in my nose
and I gotta say we had a [__] good
time we had a great time we did did you
have as good a time as I did absolutely
three hours over at that moment he drove
an hour and a half in one way yeah and
an hour and a half back we had the radio
on and we got into a really great
conversation what shut-in will you drive
next uh you've driven this shot in you
should just started serving I know I
take out you know recluses out on the
road again I don't know we're gonna have
to think about that by the way you
should also announce your new TV show
it's called recluses and cars going
nowhere hahaha
foreign